today we're going to talk about the five
best exercises for
recovering your knee now i've done other
videos on knee pain
but i haven't done any videos on how to
strengthen the knee especially after an
injury or in the process of recovering
these five exercises not only strengthen
the muscles in the knee but provide
symmetry between the left and right knee
and also the muscles on the front of the
knee versus the muscles in the back of
the knee which is very very important
because normally a person will injure
either
one knee or an ankle
and that sets up a pattern of putting
the pressure on the opposite knee and
over time that can really create some
asymmetrical stress
so
let's say 20 years ago you hurt your
right ankle
and now the left knee is hurting simply
because of the years of compensation
that occurred
so i am going to show you
a very powerful balancing technique
for pain and just balancing the muscles
after this video but let's just talk
about these five exercises now just to
learn the anatomy real quick you have
this the longest bone in the body which
is also the strongest it's called the
femur and that's the top part of the leg
which is covered by
the front muscles the thigh muscles
called the quadriceps and then the
muscles in the back part are called the
hamstrings okay now the knee joint is
really the largest hinge joint in the
body okay so you have flexion and
extension with some slight
minor rotation
but this top femur bone is connected
with a bottom
tibia bone which is the second longest
bone in the body and so this is where a
lot of weight has to be supported on
this joint right here and then on the
side of the tibia on the outside of the
leg okay we're looking at the viewpoint
of someone's right knee okay going from
the front
on the outer part
of this tibia this lower bone here you
have another bone called the fibula the
purpose of the fibula is to really
stabilize that ankle to allow you to
perform all the amazing movements and
running and different
motions that you can actually perform
then we have this thing called the
patella that's your kneecap that's right
in front and that glides right over the
tendon that's connected to the quadricep
femoris it's just going to glide over
that tendon right there and then you
have four ligaments ligaments go from
bone to bone okay
a tendon goes from a muscle to a bone
and the purpose of those ligaments are
just to prevent
motion going from to the lateral outside
or the inside or the front or the back
or twisting so it keeps everything
really really nice and tight
you also have this very hard piece of
cartilage that is connected to the bone
on the top and the bottom that is called
articular cartilage and then right in
between you have this little shock
absorber called the meniscus so that's
your anatomy a lesson of the knee joint
so let's dive right into the four
exercises the first exercise we're going
to talk about is the quad stretch so the
quad stretch improves
the hip flexor
which is up in the hip as well as the
quadricep itself and we're going to be
balancing out the flexibility of your
left quadricep to your right quadricep
so basically you're going to be standing
up supporting yourself with a wall okay
so you'll be holding on the wall with
one hand and with the other hand you'll
grab your foot or ankle
as you're pulling it up into your
hamstring and you're going to be
stretching the quadricep make mental
note of the flexibility of the right
side versus the left side because
usually you're going to find one that is
way tighter than the other one and
that's the one you want to work on more
and so then you're just going to stretch
and hold for 30 seconds okay each side
and you're just going to do that twice
okay so that's the quad stretch the next
stretch is going to be the heel to calf
stretch for this one you're going to
have your hands on the wall and you're
going to move back so your toes are
facing forward
make sure the heels are flat
with your knee slightly bent
then you're going to lean into the
stretch and hold for 30 seconds and then
when you're done with that you'll do the
opposite leg and so you're going to do
this exercise back and forth just two
times so this exercise is going to
stretch the back part of your leg as
compared to the quad stretch which
stretches the front part of the leg all
right the next stretch is called the
half squat and this is more of a
strengthening exercise where you're
going to stretch the quadricep the
glutamas muscle which is your butt
muscle as well as your hamstrings so
you're going to get in a standing
position and then you're going to
slightly squat downward and make sure
that your feet are shoulder width apart
you're just going to squat down about 10
inches
at a halfway point so you're not all the
way down to a 45 degree angle and at
this point you're just going to pause
for a few seconds and then stand up so
you're completely erect so basically
this is a half squat or a partial squat
and you're basically going to do this 10
reps and you'll do two to three sets
of these 10 repetitions we want to keep
it easy we don't want to create too much
stress but we do want to start building
up the quadricep
the buttocks muscle as well as your
hamstring all right number four let's
talk about the hamstring curl now with
this exercise you'll be standing facing
a wall for support your feet will be hip
width apart you're going to lift one
foot up bend the knee and raise your
heel towards the ceiling
go as far as you can
while keeping your upper body still with
your hips facing forward hold for five
to ten seconds you'll do ten repetitions
two to three times all right now that
you did the hamstring curl
let's move to number five and that's
called the straight leg raisers now it's
important to know that your quadricep
and your hip flexors
help raise the leg and so this exercise
will help strengthen
both of those flexors now what you want
to do is you want to flex your foot
upward so you feel your shin muscles
contracting and as you do this exercise
and get better you want to add some
weight to your ankle so you can start
off with adding a five pound weight and
then eventually going up to maybe a
seven or eight pound weight and then
even a ten pound weight but for now
we're going to do it without weights
i would highly suggest using some type
of mat
while you're laying down or you can do
this on the carpet so you're going to be
laying down the floor with one leg bent
and the other leg straight out in front
of you and so now you're going to
contract the quadricep on the leg that
is extended straight and slowly raise it
off the floor until it's at the same
height as the bent knee then you're
going to pause for about five seconds
and then lower the position down to the
mat and repeat for 10 repetitions do
this two to three times all right those
are the five exercises that are going to
put symmetry and strength and
flexibility into your legs which
surround your knees now the next
important video to watch is how to get
rid of knee pain okay you're going to
like this video check it out